Superhero movies crowded 2018's film release
schedule, not to mention the growing number
of superhero television shows, and of course
the comics upon which everything else has
been based.
And with more superhero media comes a higher
superhero body count.
In the season 3 finale of DC’s Legends of
Tomorrow, the time-hopping team lost the guy
who brought them all together: the former
Time Master Rip Hunter, played by Arthur Darvill.
“The name’s Rip Hunter.
I’m from East London.
Oh, and THE FUTURE!”
Hunter had spent the entire third season obsessed
with the demon Mallus, to the point where
he was even discharged from his job as a Time
Master.
It makes sense, then, that he met his fate
battling against that same demon, detonating
a Time Core in order to save his friends,
and sacrificing his life in the process.
Unfortunately, that explosion only wounded
Mallus, but the Legends were eventually able
to defeat the demon thanks to a 12-foot teddy
bear.
No, really.
"I luh-luh-love you."
Considering that the entire show is built
around time travel and the occasional alternate
reality, it wouldn’t be much of a stretch
to see Darvil back in action in a future season.
In the meantime, though, the Legends will
have to fend for themselves.
R.I.P., Rip.
Avengers: Infinity War brought a lot of death
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe, claiming
a higher superhero body count than any other
MCU film to date.
He certainly wouldn’t be the last, but the
major character with the dubious honor of
dying first was Heimdall, as played by Idris
Elba.
Having helped shepherd the surviving Asgardians
to safety at the end of Thor: Ragnarok, Heimdall
was on board the refugee ship when Thanos
and his Black Order attacked.
At the start of the film, he’s already seriously
injured, and in no position to help Thor,
Loki, and the Hulk in their initial skirmish
with Thanos.
At least, not at first.
Presumably hoping that Bruce Banner would
warn the heroes of Earth that Thanos was on
his way, Heimdall used the last of his strength
to activate the Bifrost and send the Hulk
back to Earth… right before Thanos impaled
him.
By the time Avengers: Infinity War rolled
around, Loki had already “died” twice,
only to prove that he was a little more resilient
than the rest of the Asgardians assumed.
This time, though, it’s tough to imagine
him pulling off that same trick again.
After handing over the Tesseract — which
turned out to be an Infinity Stone — it
seemed like Loki might go back to his old
tricks and ally himself with Thanos, just
like he had back in the first Avengers film.
The act tricked everyone, including Thor,
but it wasn’t enough to stop Thanos.
In the end, the Mad Titan easily choked the
life out of the God of Mischief.
Considering all the innocents who died at
Loki’s hands during the Battle of Manhattan,
not to mention the murder of his biological
father, attempted genocide of the Frost Giants,
and various other crimes...
“He transformed himself into a snake and
he knows that I love snakes so I went to pick
up the snake to admire it and he transformed
back into himself and went BAH it’s me!
and then he stabbed me.”
….it’s pretty easy to argue that Loki
doesn’t belong on any list of fallen heroes.
That said, his actions at the end of Ragnarok
and a noble sacrifice in Infinity War show
that he’s more than just another supervillain.
Of all the deaths doled out by Thanos in Avengers:
Infinity War, the only one that he showed
any regret for was the murder of his adopted
daughter Gamora.
After she revealed the location of the Soul
Stone to stop Thanos from torturing Nebula,
Gamora led Thanos to the planet Vormir.
On that desolate world, a ghostly apparition
of the Red Skull appeared to them, and explained
that in order to gain the Soul Stone, Thanos
had to sacrifice the thing he loved most.
“You failed… do you want to know why?
Because you love nothing.”
Much to her own surprise, it turned out that
the only thing Thanos loved was Gamora herself,
and while she tried to kill herself before
Thanos could, he threw her from a cliff to
claim his prize.
As someone who has an Infinity Stone embedded
in his head that’s keeping him alive, the
Vision was on the chopping block from the
start of Infinity War.
Admittedly, every single being in the universe
was in danger in that movie, but for Vision,
the threat was pretty direct, and involved
everyone else doing their best to protect
him including Captain America.
Once he learns of Thanos' plans, Vision insists
the only choice was to let Scarlet Witch use
her powers to destroy the Mind Stone, but
despite a group of Marvel Universe super-geniuses
working on it, there was no way to get it
out safely.
When Thanos arrived in Wakanda with every
other Infinity Stone under his command, Scarlet
Witch destroys the Mind Stone, killing Vision
in the process… only for Thanos to use the
powers of the Time Stone to put Vision back
together -- so that he could take him out
in his own, special, mind-stone-extracting
way.
Avengers: Infinity War ended with a cliffhanger
so dark, it made Empire Strikes Back say,
"Dude.
Lighten up."
It probably goes without saying, but one of
the comics that heavily influenced Infinity
War was Marvel’s 1991 miniseries, Infinity
Gauntlet.
In the comic, the story begins when Thanos
gathers all six Infinity Stones and, with
a snap of his fingers, kills half the sentient
beings in the universe including a whole lot
of superheroes, which kept the cast to a relatively
manageable size.
Infinity War saved that moment for the conclusion,
and it's devastating, and far more horrific
than the source material.
In the comics, people just blinked out of
existence.
In Infinity War, they feel what's coming before
it hits, and they're slowly erased, inch by
inch, until there's nothing left.
By the time the credits roll we watch Bucky,
Falcon, Scarlet Witch, Black Panther, Spider-Man,
Groot, Star-Lord, Drax, Mantis, and Doctor
Strange all get erased from the canvas of
reality.
In the film's one and only post-credits scene,
we see similar fates befall Maria Hill and
Nick Fury.
Considering that there are already confirmed
sequels in the works for Guardians of the
Galaxy, Black Panther, and Spider-Man: Homecoming,
“What the F?”
it's a safe bet that not all of these dusty
deaths will stick, but we won’t know for
sure until Avengers 4 finally hits theaters.
If there were an Oscar for misleading trailers,
Deadpool 2 would be bringing home at least
one statue.
In spite of being featured in at least one
action scene in the ads, Bedlam, an obscure
mutant played in the film by Terry Crews,
was the first of Wade Wilson's X-Force to
kick the bucket.
He even did it before he got to throw a single
punch.
In order to protect an imprisoned teenage
mutant from the vengeful, time-hopping Cable,
Deadpool formed his own X-Force team with
designs on an air drop to a prisoner transport
convoy.
Unfortunately for this new crop of heroes,
high-speed winds blew the team off course
and save for Deadpool and Domino the whole
roster of X-Force ended up being killed.
Bedlam was blown face-first into the windshield
of a public bus.
“NO!
Tripping Motherf------- Billies!”
In the darkly hilarious carnage that followed,
the most surprising death was Shatterstar.
A long-time X-Force member in the comics,
Shatterstar was heavily featured in the trailers,
but sadly wound up on the wrong end of a helicopter
and got chopped to pieces.
Moviegoers didn’t even get to see his cool
swords!
They have two blades!
Next up on X-Force’s list of untimely deaths
was the Vanisher.
He was one of the X-Men’s earliest comic
book villains, but when he showed up (or didn’t)
in Deadpool 2, no one was really sure if Telford
Porter, the teleporting mutant with what might
be the worst name in comics history, actually
existed.
Eventually, though, it turned out that he
was a full-fledged member of the team, and
moviegoers got a glimpse at just who was behind
his less-than-visible presence..
“Maybe the wind can’t blow what it can’t
see.”
“REALLY!?”
In the comics, Zeitgeist is the leader of
a reality-show celebrity version of X-Force…
for about five minutes.
He actually dies in the same issue where he
makes his first appearance, along with most
of his team, so if nothing else, Deadpool
2 has that bit of true-to-canon accuracy going
for it.
Also accurate: his extremely gross super-power
of barfing acid.
The bad news well, worse news is that we only
get to see that power when Zeitgeist winds
up in a woodchipper.
The powerless Peter tries to save his new
teammate, only to get his arm… um acided?
off by Zeitgeist’s vomit.
And die himself.
That’s gross enough to make you long for
helicopter blades or a speeding bus, but at
least Peter was saved by Deadpool’s time-hopping
mini-adventure at the end.
When Deadpool uses Cable's time machine to
undo Vanessa and Peter's deaths in the mid-credits
sequence of Deadpool 2, he also uses it to
correct some more notorious mistakes.
X-Men Origins: Wolverine is often considered
a low point for Deadpool fans, mostly because
it turned the famously talkative Wade Wilson
into into a mouthless, murderous Mortal Kombat
ripoff.
As much as you may hate that movie, Ryan Reynolds
has shown us that he probably hates it more,
parodying that movie’s action in Deadpool
2 with some flashy but completely ineffective
sword action.
"Whoo, those bullets are like, super fast."
That still wasn’t enough, though, so once
he gets his hands on some time travel, Deadpool’s
first priority is to head back to 2009 to
fire bullet after bullet into his previous
incarnation.
While most of Ant-Man and the Wasp takes place
before the events of Avengers: Infinity War,
the post-credits scenes caught up to the Avengers'
ill-fated battle with Thanos.
In those, we learned that the original Ant-Man
and both women who went by the codename Wasp
were victims of Thanos' infamous "snap,”
leaving only their dust blowing in the breeze.
Before they set their sights on Shatter, the
anti-mutant hate-group called the Purifiers
were bad, but hadn’t gone as far as murder.
Then, in the 19th episode of the series, that
line is crossed.
It started when disgraced Sentinel Agent Jace
Turner joined the Purifiers.
He seemed intent on changing their method,
but after finding the location of the Mutant
Underground’s base, he led an attack with
lethal consequences.
Shatter volunteered to distract the Purifiers,
and while most of their weapons couldn’t
penetrate his skin, Agent Turner brought heavier
ordinance.
Clearly conflicted but ultimately resolved
to his course, Turner unloaded a machine gun
at Shatter, killing him.
"Elseworlds" the 2018 crossover that ran through
the majority of the CW's Arrowverse series
was highly anticipated for its live-action
debut of Ruby Rose as Batwoman, the role reversals
of Barry Allen and Oliver Queen, and Superman's
black suit.
"I decide who’s story ends.”
“ … I like you better in blue"
The
episodes immediately preceding the crossover
for each respective participating series ended
with the same brief scene of destruction:
the lifeless bodies of superheroes scattered
around a war-torn landscape.
Most of the corpses' faces were hidden, but
judging by the costumes, the dead heroes from
Earth-90 included the Ray, Hawkman, Hawkgirl,
Firestorm, Huntress, Captain Cold, and Stargirl.
The only survivor of Earth-90's heroes was
the Flash, who flees his world before the
Monitor can destroy it.
We don't know if the older Flash survived
the crossover.
After he contacts the heroes of Earth-1, the
Earth-90 Flash fights beside them when they
launch a brief and futile attack on the Monitor.
With just a motion of the Monitor's hand,
Earth-90 Flash disappears in a cloud of smoke
and never reappears.
Monitor uses similar powers on other heroes
without killing them, but since Earth-90 no
longer exists it's unclear where Monitor sent
the older Flash.
"Go find someone else to prank, douchebag"
Probably the most blatant way the animated
film Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse differed
from the comic book event that inspired it
is the film doesn't have much of a body count.
Marvel's Spider-Verse crossover didn't just
introduce loads of alternate reality versions
of Spider-Man it killed a whole bunch of them,
too.
Obviously Into the Spider-Verse wanted a family-friendly
appeal that would be spoiled by the brutal
murders of dozens of spider-themed heroes,
but there was one victim among its spiders.
Peter Parker is dispatched by the Kingpin
early in the film.
Miles Morales and the other Spider heroes
rally at the home of Peter's Aunt May, where
we learn the late Parker kept his own "Spider-Cave"
below May's backyard shed.
Parker's death partly mirrored the character's
fate in the now-defunct Ultimate line of Marvel's
comics.
The Ultimate version of Peter Parker died
while fighting the Green Goblin and was replaced
by the new Spider-Man, Miles Morales.
"Thwip and release"
"You're a natural"
“Feel the rhythm?”